>> Jeff: AND PAUL GEORGE IS
GOING TO RUE THOSE TWO FREE
THROWS DOWN THE STRETCH.
THAT COULD HAVE PUT THEM UP
THREE.
>> Mike: DEANDRE AYTON, 24
POINTS, 14 REBOUNDS.
AND THE BIGGEST BUCKET OF THE
NIGHT, HE'S WITH CASSIDY.
>> Cassidy: FROM THE PLAY MONTY
DREW UP TO THE PASS FROM DAY,
CAN YOU WALK ME THROUGH THE
EXECUTION OF YOUR GAME-WINNING
SHOT?
>> MAN, I JUST TRUST MY
TEAMMATES AND COACHES.
I LISTENED TO WHAT THEY TOLD ME
TO DO.
JAE MADE A GREAT PASS, AND I
JUST FINISHED.
I'M GLAD IT COUNTED.
WE JUST WANTED TO FINISH THE
GAME OFF STRONG.
>> Cassidy: THIS IS A GRITTY,
PHYSICAL GAME.
I SAW YOU TALKING TO DEVIN
BOOKER AT THE END OF THE GAME,
PLAYING WITH THE TWO STITCHES IN
HIS NOSE.
THE CLIPPERS DON'T GIVE UP.
HOW DO YOU FEEL YOU RESPONDED TO
THEIR PUNCHES?
>> HATS OFF TO THE CLIPPERS.
THEY'RE A TOUGH TEAM.
BUT WE DID WHAT WE HAVE TO DO,
AND BIG PROBLEMS TO D-BOOK,
COMING BACK.
I HOPE HIS NOSE ISN'T BROKEN,
BUT HE SHOWED A LOT OF CHARACTER
COMING BACK AND HELPING TO CLOSE
THIS OUT.
>> Cassidy: THIS WAS A REALLY
FUN GAME TO WATCH.
I'M SURE CHRIS PAUL ENJOYED IT,
BUT HE WOULD MUCH RATHER BE
HERE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK CHRIS WOULD
SAY TO YOU AFTER THIS WIN?
>> MAN, I THINK HE WOULD SAY,
HECK, YEAH.
WAY TO GO, BIG FELLA.
STUFF LIKE THAT, JUST HYPING ME
UP.
ENJOYING THE GAME